نجوم على ثلاثة ، أحب لعب القوة
حول الجوانب لأنها تجعلني أشعر
بالقوة أنا فخور باللعب لنجوم الصالون
لأنني أمثل
فتيات مسلمات أخريات في جميع أنحاء العالم ، فهذه
النجوم أكبر من كرة السلة
لأننا نكسر كل الصور النمطية  من
العالم لمطاردتنا ، أريد
أن يعرف الناس أننا مجرد مجموعة من
الفتيات المراهقات اللاتي يأتين للعب
كرة السلة والعمل بجد قدر الإمكان
والفوز ، هذا هو هدفنا
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي ديفيد وينهام ، انظر إلي  كابتن
في هذه المدرسة اللعينة ، نجوم المدرسة ، يصفعون المدارس
من جميع المدارس الإسلامية الخاصة ، ويصفعوا
النجوم ، كان فريق كرة السلة للفتيات
من جميع الرياضات المسلمات اللاتي وصلن إلى
هناك ويمثلن دينًا أثناء
لعب كرة السلة في العام الماضي ،
فزنا بالعديد من المباريات.  الفريق
والطريقة التي وصلنا بها إلى أن نكون فريقًا رائعًا هي
عملنا الجاد ، وكيمياءنا خاصة
الطريقة التي نلعب بها ، فنحن نوعًا ما مثل عائلة
، من المهم أن يكون لديك هذا النوع من الترابط
لأن الناس ينظرون إلينا بازدراء
بسبب ما نرتديه  ثم أعتقد أننا لا
نعرف كيف نلعب ولكن عندما نخرج إلى
هناك ونوضح لهم كيف نلعب ، يكون الأمر
رائعًا لأننا أظهرنا لهم
من نحن حقًا كفريق
[موسيقى]
كنت ألعب كرة السلة  منذ أن كنت في
الثالثة عشر من
عمري ، كنت أشاهد إخوتي يلعبون وكان
الأمر حولي طوال الوقت ، لأن
كرة السلة شديدة الشدة وأنت
تتنقل ، وأنا أحب اللياقة البدنية
التي ساعدتني في وجود عائلة داعمة
كثيرًا لأنها تجعلني أشعر
بالثقة في
اللعب  كرة السلة خاصة لأننا
نفعل ذلك لأن ديننا من
خلال لعبها على الطريق يشبه نوعًا من
ترك كل الدعم الذي لديك خلفك
وأنت تذهب إلى مدرسة حيث
لا يعرف الناس حقًا ما هو دينك في
بعض الأحيان نراهم  الضحك
والشعور وكأنه يهمس لبعضكما البعض ،
إنه أمر محبط
لأنك تحاول الفوز بالمباراة وبعد ذلك يكون لديك
مثل التعليقات السلبية في أذنك ولكن
في نفس الوقت علينا أن نتغلب
على الكراهية التي قلناها لزملائي فقط.
إعادة ذلك وإذا لم يتمكنوا من تجاهله ،
أظهر لهم فقط من خلال لعب كرة السلة ،
فلا تضغط بقوة من خلال ما
يقولون إن
فريق المدربين يعرف ما نمر به داخل
وخارج الملعب
، ومع مرور السنين ، تعلمت
الكثير منا عندما  وصلت إلى هنا في البداية
لم أكن أعرف أي شيء عن الإسلام
واعتمدت على القيادة العليا الأكبر سناً
في الفريق وحتى يومنا هذا ، فأنا أعتمد
على كبار القادة ليخبروني مثل ما إذا
كان وقت الصلاة
سيأتون إليّ.  كمدرب ، هل يمكننا أن نصلي على
الإطلاق ، لا يتعلق الأمر فقط بكرة السلة هنا ،
فنحن نحاول بناء شابات واثقات من
أنفسهن ، لكني أشعر بالرهبة من الطريقة التي
تحمل بها الفتيات أنفسهن جيدًا ، وأنا فخور جدًا
بكوني
مدربتهن.  لا يتعلق الأمر بالرياضة فحسب ، بل يتعلق الأمر
بكيفية العمل معًا ، والالتزام
الذي تقدمه للفريق والطريقة التي تلعب بها
معًا في الملعب بغض النظر عما
يحدث ، فأنت تلعب بأقصى ما لديك ، أريد
أن يعرف الناس أن
الرياضات المسلمات لا يختلفن نحن
الفتيات اللواتي يرغبن فقط في لعب كرة السلة
نحن لا نختلف عن أي
فريق فتيات آخر نحن فخورون بأننا نرتدي
الوشاح ونفخر بأننا نقدم
دين لعب كرة السلة ولن يوقفنا شيء